uh but today first i have the
privilege of introducing for the first
time uh to this room
the 71st secretary of state uh mr tony
lincoln so with no further ado turn over
to
thank you good afternoon um
let me start by saying that my first
ambition is to be known as the uh
man who brought ned price to the state
department briefing room
and that at least is mission
accomplished
well uh in in in all seriousness uh
thanks to everyone for joining me uh
here
today um this is my first full day on
the job
as uh secretary of state and uh
to restate what i said before it is a
deep honor
uh to be in this job and i am uh
gratified that uh the president has seen
fit to entrust me this responsibility
and i am incredibly excited about the
work ahead
um especially working with the men
and women of the state department uh to
try to serve the american people
and represent our country uh to the
world um
i wanted to spend a few minutes with uh
with all of you today uh to make it
clear right from the start
how important i see the work that each
and every one of you does some of you
may know that
i started my career as a journalist
obviously i didn't didn't succeed but it
was
something that i took tremendous
pride and pleasure in and something i
have deep respect for as a result of my
own
experience being on both sides of the uh
of the enterprise you keep the american
people and the world
informed about what we do here that's
key to our mission as well
um and you hold us accountable
ask tough questions and that really does
make us better
more broadly and it is never more
important to restate it
a free press is a cornerstone of our
democracy
and this is a critical moment for
protecting and defending democracy
including right here at home um so
here's what you can count on coming from
me and coming from us
uh we're resuming the daily press
briefing starting next week
on tuesday that's an essential part of
the day
and we're bringing it back president
biden has said
that he wants truth and transparency
back in the white house briefing room
that fully applies in this room as well
and you'll be seeing me with a little
bit of frequency too
uh including on our travels together
when hopefully we can get back to those
travels
uh just as you'll have an opportunity to
hear from many policy experts
uh in this uh in this building i know
we're not always going to see
uh eye to eye that's not the point of
the enterprise
um sometimes will be frustrating to you
i imagine there are a few times when
you'll be frustrating uh to us
uh but that's to be expected that's
exactly uh in some ways the point
um but you can count on me
you can count on us to treat all of you
with the immense respect you deserve and
to give you what
you need to do the jobs that you're
doing that are so important
to our country and to our democracy um
and i will be forthright uh whether it's
behind this podium
on the plane or hopefully eventually
some
distant uh part of the world so it's uh
it's an adventure uh i am really really
glad
that we're in together uh so welcome
back to the press room as
ned said this is your press room and
with that
uh let me take a few questions
thank you uh welcome back mr secretary
to the building thank you
thank you for your kind words about our
profession
earlier i'll try to be as brief as uh
possible in the last couple months of
the of the the previous administration
several policies were rolled out and
enacted um
that attracted a bunch of they were
contentious to say
the least or attack attracted a bunch of
criticism i i realize that a lot of
almost everything is under review right
now as you're less than 24 hours in but
among those things that were enacted in
the last several months
which are your priorities to for
to complete the review to possibly
reverse or send
a roll back and similarly within the
building
apart from policy but in terms of
personnel
what exactly do you intend to change if
anything about the
approach the previous administration
took to the foreign service and people
worked in this building
thanks uh yes you're right we are
reviewing a number of steps that we're
taking
taken late in the last uh administration
we want to make sure we understand
uh in each case the the basis uh for the
decisions that were uh were made um i
will tell you that
i'm particularly focused on uh the
question of uh sanctions on the houthis
uh i think you all know very well
uh the houthis committed an act of uh
significant aggression in uh taking over
sana'a some years ago
uh moving through the country committing
acts of aggression against
our partner saudi arabia committing
human rights abuses and other atrocities
creating an environment
in which we've seen extremist groups
fill some of the vacuums that
that were created but at the same time
we've seen a campaign uh led by saudi
arabia
that has also contributed to what is by
many estimates the worst humanitarian uh
crisis
uh in the world today and that's saying
something and so it's vitally important
even in the midst of this crisis that we
do everything we can
to get humanitarian assistance to uh the
people of yemen
who are in desperate need and what we
want to make sure is that any steps we
are taking
do not uh get in the way of providing
that uh
that assistance uh the uh houthis
controlled territory
that i believe um contains about 80
percent
of uh yemen's population and so
we want to make sure that any of these
steps including the designation
uh don't make what is already uh a
an incredibly difficult task even more
difficult that is the provision of
humanitarian aid
to the people of yemen so we're taking a
very urgent
and very close look at that we want to
make sure that not only
are american aid groups able to
do what they can to provide assistance
but so are age groups around the world
that are providing the bulk
of that assistance and to make sure that
nothing we are doing um
interferes with that uh particularly if
it doesn't uh
in any other way advance our uh our
policy and objectives so that's the uh
that's the priority in my in my book
thank you very much congratulations mr
secretary good to see you
um president biden in his first phone
call
with president putin yesterday outlined
some areas of agreement such as the arms
control agreement the extension of
new start but at the same time areas of
concern
many of which involved russia we're
talking about solar winds hack
and ukraine of course the investigation
the assessment
of interference in the 2020 campaign but
also
uh also the safety of alexei navalny
and so i want to ask you what are the
red lines
under which the united states would
consider sanctioning russia
if there's any harm that comes to mr
navami
or to the protesters as they're being
arrested you know how
front and center is this issue to you of
russian crackdown on the opposition and
on human rights
uh well thanks andrea we've uh as you
know uh already expressed
uh our deep concern for the uh for the
treatment of mr navalny uh
specifically and more generally with the
human rights situation in russia and
it remains striking to me
how concerned and maybe even scared
the russian government seems to be of
one man uh mr navalny
um across the board as the president has
said
we're reviewing uh all of these actions
uh that uh
are deep concern to us whether it is uh
the treatment of mr navalny
and particularly uh the apparent use of
a chemical weapon
uh in an attempt to uh assassinate him
uh
we're looking uh very urgently as well
at solar winds and its various
implications we're looking at the
reports of
bounties placed by
russia on american forces in afghanistan
and of course we're looking at these
questions of election interference
so all of that as the the president and
white house have indicated
are under review i don't want to get
ahead of uh where we are uh
on those reviews but um as i say we have
a
deep concern uh for mr navalny's safety
and uh
and security uh and and the larger point
is that uh
uh his voice is the voice of many many
many russians uh
and uh it uh should be heard not uh not
muzzled
and you're not ruling out anything if
there's harm that comes to you um
not not ruling out anything but we want
to get uh get this full review done and
then we'll take it from there all right
thanks mr secretary um
as head of the correspondents
association here thank you for coming
out on your first day it's
it's a powerful signal and it does go uh
does go notice by us um
could i ask you in your confirmation
hearing you spoke uh
in support of the so-called abraham
accords under the previous
administration
uh a couple of decisions that your
administration could take i wanted to
ask you about
um i understand there's a review going
on right now about military sales
uh the f-35 sales to the united emirates
and sales to saudi arabia
how do you see those going forward uh do
you plan on the f-35s eventually going
forward to the uae
and with morocco um does the united
states still recognize
uh as the previous administration said
moroccan sovereignty in
western sahara thank you thank you
thanks very much um
a couple of things on that uh first as
uh
as we've said uh we uh very much support
the abraham accords
uh we think that uh uh
israel normalizing relations with uh
with its neighbors
and other countries in the region is a
very positive development
uh and so uh we applauded them and uh we
hope that there may be an opportunity to
uh to build on them in the months and
uh uh and years ahead uh we're also
trying to make sure that we have a full
understanding
of any commitments that may have been
made in uh securing
uh those agreements and that's something
we're uh we're looking at right now
um generally speaking when it comes to
uh to arm sales
it is uh typical uh at the start of an
administration
uh to um review uh any uh any
any penny sales uh to make sure that uh
what is being considered
uh is uh something that advances our
strategic objectives
uh and advances our foreign policy so
that's uh that's what we're doing at
this moment
mr secretary what are you looking at and
uh do you plan on retaining
ambassador khalil's uh as us
um with regard to uh to afghanistan
one of the things that we need to
understand is uh exactly what is in
the agreements that were reached between
the united states and the taliban
to make sure that we fully understand
the commitments that the taliban has
made as well as any commitments
that we've made and so uh we are taking
that up and with regard to ambassador
calzod yes
uh we have uh we've asked him to
continue uh the vital work that he's
performing
nick chang with voa thank you so much um
good luck afternoon mr secretary how are
you well thank you
um if i make good uh if i may on china
how um how do you cooperate with china
in climate change
when you say you agree that it's engaged
in genocide
and separately kurt campbell has
mentioned some confidence beauty
measures such as
loosening up of journalistic visa
restrictions and reversing the consular
closing
closure is that happening thank you
thank you very much
um we've had some opportunity to talk
about this uh in recent
recent weeks in recent months and i
think it's it's not a secret that
um the relationship between the united
states
and china is arguably the most important
relationship
uh that we have uh in the world going
going forward
uh it's going to shape a lot of the
future that that we all live
and uh increasingly that relationship
has some adversarial aspects to it it
has competitive ones
uh and it also still has cooperative
ones
uh and the cooperative ones are in areas
where it's uh in our mutual interest
uh to try to uh to work together
including
manifestly uh on climate uh where it's
in the interest of china and the
interest of the united states and
industry countries around the world uh
to make
uh concrete progress in combating uh
global warming and so uh i think uh and
and hope that we'll be able to pursue
that but
that fits within the larger context of
uh of our foreign policy
and of uh many issues of concern that we
have
with with china issues that we need to
need to work through and so i think
you'll see us
doing uh doing just that even as we
pursue
the climate agenda that is so important
to our country into the future
of our planet for final question to you
uh tomorrow
hello mr secretary himera from reuters
um i want to ask you about iran
they said they would like united states
to lift all the sanctions first
while you said they need to
come back in full compliance so how do
you plan to reconcile that
and when should we expect to open the
negotiations and who would lead them for
united states and if i may own
china you talked about
reviews and with respect to uyghurs and
xinjiang in your confirmation hearing
you endorsed the genocide
determination but today linda tom
screenfield said the department is
reviewing
um that determination is that only about
the process
or are there different views on on this
determination and
should we expect some more punitive
action throughout this
okay so i haven't actually seen what
ambassador thomas greenfield said so i
can't
uh i can't comment on it but i
my judgment remains that
genocide was committed against against
the uyghurs and
that that hasn't changed um
with regard to iran
president biden has been uh very clear
in saying that uh
if iran comes back into
full compliance with its obligations
under the jcpoa
uh the united states uh would do the
same thing and then we would use that
uh as a platform uh to build with our
allies and partners
uh what we call a longer uh and stronger
agreement and to deal with
a number of other issues that are deeply
problematic
in the relationship with iran
but we are a long ways from that point
iran is out of compliance uh on a number
of fronts
and uh it would take some time should it
make the decision to do so for it to
come back into compliance
and time for us then to assess uh
whether it was meeting its obligations
so
we're not uh we're not there yet to say
the least
um and then with regard to uh
how we would engage this issue if iran
decides to come back into compliance
uh i can tell you that we will um we
will build a a strong team
of experts and uh we will bring to bear
different perspectives uh on the issue
uh we this uh this is something
i would say this across the board by the
way um one of the things that i feel
very strongly about
is that in any of the issues we're
engaged on in any of the issues that
we're tackling
and that our foreign policy has to
confront uh that uh
we are constantly questioning our own
assumptions and premises
uh that we uh we do not engage in in
group think
that there is uh as much um
self-criticism and self-reflection as uh
we get
from appropriately uh the outside
whether it's from
from you or whether it's from people who
disagree with the policies we're
pursuing so i think you can expect
uh to see that as we move forward both
with regard potentially to iran
uh and for that matter to just about any
other issue we we tackle thank you
thank you congratulations
uh you've talked a lot about restoring
u.s leadership in the world
but allies note that everything that you
do could again be overturned in four
years and that
this as a cycle that doesn't instill
confidence in the long term and the
united states credibility
so how can any one administration if it
can be done
um assure the world that the united
states can be trusted to keep its
commitments
so one of the things i've done over the
last uh 24 hours i've spent a lot of
time
on the phone already with our some of
our closest allies and partners
uh in in various parts of the world and
that's that's continuing
um and i can what i've picked up from
those conversations already
is a very very strong desire for the
united states
to be back in the room back at the table
working with him
on the many many common challenges we
face
and that was almost palpable in the uh
in the conversations i've had to date
and uh i expect to hear more of that in
the uh in the days ahead
one of the things though uh to your
point is that
when it comes to virtually everything
we're we're doing
um and the president has said this many
times when uh
when it comes to foreign policy it it it
is hard to have
a sustainable foreign policy absent the
informed consent
of the american people and that informed
consent i think comes
in in a couple of ways um one is in a
sense
it comes from you uh because uh many
uh americans are uh reading about
hearing about
uh listening to what we're doing uh
thanks to you
and that's vitally important to make
sure that they are fully informed
uh and thinking about and ultimately
providing their consent to what we're
doing
but the place that in our system that
informed consent
is vitally important is uh is with
congress
uh the members of congress uh are
the representatives of the american
people uh they provide advice and
consent
to uh to our policies and i think one of
the things you're going to see
from from our administration
is working as closely as we possibly can
with congress on these issues
from the takeoff not just on the landing
because ultimately for these policies to
be sustainable
we i think need to try to work them as
much as we can up front
uh not at the uh at the back end
they're going to be disagreements
they're going to be places where we uh
we're just in a different place
but i think we stand a better chance in
producing the kind of policies that will
stand the test of time
if we're working closely up front uh
with congress
uh and we'll see where we get but i'm
determined uh that we do that
thank you very much thank you all
look forward to seeing you uh soon and
often
can we see you on the plane all right
yeah well really look forward to that
but um
not tomorrow
thank you